[Música]
son las 4 a.m y en 8 horas tiene un
examen importante seguido por un recital
de piano ha estudiado y practicado
durante días pero todavía no se siente
preparado
Entonces qué puede hacer Bueno puede
beber otra taza de café y pasar las
próximas horas estudiando y practicando
pero aunque no lo crea Puede que sea
mejor que cierre los libros guarde el
piano y vaya a dormir Dormir ocupa casi
un tercio de nuestras vidas pero
sorprendentemente muchos le prestan poca
atención
este descuido es muchas veces resultado
de un gran malentendido dormir No es
perder el tiempo o solo una manera de
descansar cuando terminamos de trabajar
el sueño es una función crucial en la
que el cuerpo equilibra y monitorea los
sistemas vitales eso afecta la
respiración y regulación de todo desde
la circulación hasta el crecimiento y la
respuesta inmunitaria eso es fantástico
Pero puede preocuparse por esas cosas
luego del examen no bueno no tan rápido
resulta que el sueño también es crucial
para el cerebro ya que un quinto de la
sangre del cuerpo se dirige hacia allí
mientras duerme
y el período de sueño es de una
reestructuración intensamente activa
esencial para el funcionamiento de la
memoria
a primera vista nuestra capacidad de
recordar cosas no parece muy
impresionante
hermann eddinghouse un psicólogo del
siglo 19 demostró que olvidamos el 40%
de lo que aprendemos dentro de los
primeros 20 minutos un fenómeno conocido
como la curva del olvido pero esta
pérdida puede prevenirse con la
consolidación de la memoria el proceso
por el cual la información Se mueve de
la breve memoria de corto plazo a la más
duradera de largo plazo
está consolidación ocurre gracias a una
parte importante del cerebro el
hipocampo su función en la formación de
la memoria a largo plazo fue demostrada
en los años 50 por ofrenda Miller en sus
estudios de un paciente conocido como HM
luego de que le quitaran el hipocampo la
capacidad de HM para formar recuerdos a
corto plazo se deterioró pero podía
aprender tareas físicas mediante la
repetición debido a esta extracción
también se deterioró su capacidad para
formar recuerdos a largo plazo este caso
reveló entre otras cosas que el
hipocampo estaba específicamente
involucrado en la consolidación de la
memoria declarativa a largo plazo
necesaria para recordar datos y
conceptos para el examen más que en la
memoria procedimental que incluye los
movimientos de los dedos que necesita
dominar para el recital los hallazgos de
Miller sumados al trabajo de Erick
candle en los años 90 nos dieron el
modelo actual del funcionamiento de este
proceso de consolidación la información
sensorial es transcripta y almacenada
temporalmente en las neuronas como
memoria a corto plazo Desde allí viaja
al hipocampo que fortalece y mejora las
neuronas en esa área
gracias a la neuroplasticidad se forman
nuevas sinapsis lo que permite nuevas
conexiones entre las neuronas y
fortalece la red neuronal a donde la
información volverá como memoria a largo
plazo Entonces por qué recordamos
algunas cosas y no otras hay algunas
formas de influenciar el alcance y la
eficacia de la retención de recuerdos
por ejemplo los recuerdos creados en
momentos de emociones intensas o incluso
estrés serán registrados mejor dada la
relación del hipocampo con las emociones
Pero uno de los grandes factores que
ayudan a la consolidación de la memoria
es dormir bien Por la noche el sueño
Está compuesto por cuatro fases las más
profundas son conocidas como sueño de
ondas lentas y sueño de movimientos
oculares rápidos more los
electroencefalogramas realizados a
personas durante estas fases han
mostrado impulsos eléctricos entre el
tronco encefálico el hipocampo el tálamo
y la corteza cerebral que funcionan como
repetidoras información de recuerdos se
ha demostrado que las diferentes fases
del sueño ayudan a consolidar distintos
tipos de memorias durante la fase de
sueño de ondas lentas se codifica la
memoria declarativa de forma provisional
en la parte frontal del hipocampo
a través de un diálogo continuo entre la
corteza y el hipocampo es reactivada de
forma reiterada hasta ser distribuida En
donde será almacenada a largo plazo en
la corteza
el sueño humor similar a la actividad
cerebral de alguien despierto se asocia
con la consolidación de la memoria
procedimental entonces de acuerdo con
los estudios acostarse tres horas
después de memorizar las fórmulas y una
hora después de practicar las escalas
sería lo ideal ahora podrá ver que
escatimar en sueño No solo daña su salud
a largo plazo sino que hace que sea
menos probable que retenga todo ese
conocimiento y práctica de la noche
anterior todo esto reafirma el dicho
consultarlo con la almohada si piensa en
la reestructuración interna y las nuevas
conexiones que se forman mientras duerme
podría hasta decir que una buena noche
de sueño hará que se despierte cada
mañana con un nuevo y mejorado cerebro
listo para enfrentar los desafíos del
día
qué sucedería si pasara la noche dando
vueltas en la cama durmiendo apenas un
poco y al día siguiente se sintiera
agotado e improductivo ayudaría a dormir
una siesta o desestabilizaría su día aún
más mire este video sobre la ciencia de
las fiestas y descubra cómo estas
rápidas y estas afectan su cerebro